well president Trump's defense of
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
took a sharp turn last night when he
publicly criticized the woman who claims
Kavanaugh sexually assaulted her in high
school the president slammed Christine
Blasi for Senate testimony during a
political rally in Mississippi with the
crowd cheering him on
her lawyer responded on Twitter is it
any wonder that she was terrified to
come forward and that other sexual
assault survivors are as well major
Garrett is at the White House which is
waiting for the FBI to finish examining
the allegations against Kavanaugh major
good morning good morning there was a
time surprising to some here at the
White House where President Trump used
measured language and exercise
discipline restraint when discussing
Brett Kavanaugh and those who had
accused him in the past of some form of
sexual misconduct those days quite
clearly are over Cavanaugh chief accuser
dr. Blasi Ford's memory is now fair game
for the President and he says Cavanaugh
is the one being victimized by a process
not because of his past conduct or his
answers under sworn testimony to the
Senate but because the president says
Cavanaugh represents a scary new
political dynamic in the confirmation
process guilty until proven innocent how
did you get home I don't remember how'd
you get there I don't remember where is
the place I don't remember how many
years ago was that I don't know
I don't know for the first time
president Trump openly mocked dr.
Christine Blasi Ford who has accused
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh of
sexually assaulting her in high school
the president who previously described
Ford's testimony as credible and
compelling ridiculed her story's missing
details what neighborhood was it and I
don't know where's the house I don't
know upstairs downstairs where was I
don't know but I had one beer that's the
only thing I remember and a man's life
is in tatters a man's life is shattered
four testified she remembered Kavanagh
clearly as the person who tried to
assault her Ford's lawyer Michael
Bromwich tweeted mr. Trump had engaged
in a vicious vile and soulless attack
adding the president was a Profile in
cowardice dr. Ford has not yet been
interviewed by the FBI is part of its
seventh background check on Cavanaugh in
a letter to FBI director Christopher Ray
dr. Ford's lawyer said it is
inconceivable that the FBI could conduct
a thorough investigation of dr. Ford's
allegations without interviewing her
Judiciary Committee chairman chuck
Grassley accused Ford's team of
withholding material evidence despite
multiple requests for notes from therapy
sessions as well as the full details of
dr. Ford's polygraph examination I drank
beer with my friends
almost everyone did letters obtained by
the New York Times appear to show
Cavanaugh riding his friends ahead of
Beach week in 1983 to warn the neighbors
that were loud obnoxious drunks with
prolific pukers among us I don't think
you should lie to Congress to me that
would not be acceptable
yesterday the president appeared to
distance himself from his nominee I
don't even know I met him for the first
time a few weeks ago I don't even know
him so it's not like oh gee I want to
protect my friend I want to do what's
right for this country Kavanagh has
denied all allegations of sexual
misconduct and excessive drinking now
Joe Manchin West Virginia Democrat
possibly a swing vote in the Cavanaugh
confirmation saga said if it's revealed
or confirmed that Cavanaugh lied to the
Senate
little support for his confirmation
would collapse John the major what do we
know about that inquiry and when it's
gonna be completed and then when the
Senate will hold its vote started Friday
Senate Republican leaders expect the FBI
FBI report to be made available to
senators Wednesday or Thursday Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader
said a vote will be held this week the
outcome of that vote though remains
highly uncertain all right major thank
you